should people be afraid of ai taking
over the world
there's a lot of things to be afraid of
with ai
i like to see it as we have a
distribution over different kinds of
outcomes
some more positive than others
so there isn't some set
at least not one that we can know
there are a lot of different things
where ai can be just super helpful super
assistive possibly
task based as opposed to more general
intelligence
and you could see it going the other way
similar to
this example i had given about um
thinking something destructive was
beautiful
like
that's one hop away from the system is
able to like press a button or the
equivalent to press a button to like set
off a missile or whatever like yeah
so i don't think people should be scared
per se but i do think that they should
think about the worst ways that things
could go and the best ways that things
can go
and aim for the best ways
and try and
mitigate
or
stop the worst ways
i think the biggest issue right now is
just on how these systems can
can widen the divide between you know
haves and have not
really like further further give power
to people who have power and
you know further worse and things for
people who don't
as the people designing these systems
are often people with more power and
wealth and they design for
their kinds of interests
yeah so
i think that's the the thing that's
happening now and one of the riskiest
things
to be thinking about in the future
but ideally if if we can focus on what's
actually most beneficial
then we can lead it in that direction